ونبدا بهشام زقوط من غزه والاجواء الان
بعد ساعه من دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
[تصفيق]
زين العابدين كما ترى هي اجواء فرح اجواء
يعني خرجت الناس الى الشوارع الجماهيره
الفلسطينيه بمختلف عناصرها وفصائلها
ومواطنيها ومدنيها خرجوا الى هذا المفترق
الرئيسي وهو مفترق السرايا وسط مدينه غزه
ورفعوا الاعلام اعلام الفصائل والاعلام
الفلسطينيه واطلق
وا عبى الناريه هللوا وكبروا
بانتهاء فرحا بانتهاء هذا التصعيد بدايه
ومع دخول
اتفاق وقت اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ بدانا
نرى هذه الحركه النشطه في الشوارع سيارات
الناس بمختلف اعمارهم خرجوا الى هذه
الشوارع فرحا بهذا الوقت لاطلاق النار
وايضا فرحا بوحده المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي
ردت العدوان الاسرائيلي
واطلقت الصواريخ وايضا
فوضت في القاهره
وصرت على ان يكون وقف اطلاق وقف
الاغتيالات جزءا اساسيا من هذا الاتفاق
والاهم بالنسبه لهم ايضا هو وقت
استهداف المنازل منازل المواطنين
والمدنيين وقبل قليل كان هناك ايضا مسير
لسيارات الاسعاف ولسيارات الدفاع المدني
التي مازال بعضها يتواجد هنا ويعتليه بعض
المواطنين فرحا ويرقصون ويتراقصون على هذه
السيارات فرحا
بفرحا بهذا الوقت لاطلاق النار كما ترى
زين العابدين فان الجماهير تخرج والحياه
بدات تعود تدريجيا الى هذه الشوارع بعد ان
توقفت الحياه بشكل بتعمل على مدار خمسه
ايام جراء هذا التصعيد الذي كان على قطاع
غزه وبدا واستمر لخمسه ايام اطلقت فيها
المقاومه العديد من الصواريخ وقصفت فيه
اسرائيل العديد من المنازل والاعراضي
الزراعيه وكان هناك مؤتمر صحفي لاياد
البوزم
المتحدث باسم وزاره الداخليه الفلسطينيه
والذي شكر فيه الجماهير واكد انهم وقفوا
الى جانب الجماهير الفلسطينيه هنا في غزه
وايضا تحدث عن
المهمات والتي قام بها قامت بها وزاره
الداخليه وايضا الوزاره الصحه وقال ان
هؤلاء الرجال سطروا ايضا وفي مقدمتهم
الدفاع المدني والخدمات الطبيه والشرطه
تمروا صورا جديده من البطوله والتضحيه من
خلال قيامهم بواجبهم اتجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني في ظل العدوان وايضا دعموا
واسندوا المواطنين المواطنين وحفظوا
استقرار الجبهه الداخليه واكد ان وزاره
الداخليه بدات بتطبيق خطه اعاده انتشار في
جميع
القطاع فورا الاعلان عن انتهاء هذا
العدوان لتقديم الخدمه اذا المواطنون الان
المقاومه استطاعت اجبار الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على السوق
لمواقفها ولشروطها